Welcome to Cloud Minute
Let's take a look at how to upload files and folders to Google Cloud Storage
First, go to the Storage Browser and select your Bucket.
You can click "Upload Files" to select files and folder from your file picker
But my favorite is the "Drag and Drop" feature.
Here, you can just Drag and Drop files and folders straight into the Web UI.
Now let's open a command line in the folder with the files we want to upload
I want to upload "file2.txt" and "folder2" to Cloud Storage
To upload "file2.txt", type in
'gsutil', then 'cp', then the name of the file 'file2.txt', and finally the name of the Cloud Storage bucket 'gs://temporal-loop-94520'
If we refresh our Google Developer Console, we can see that the new file has been uploaded
Now let's copy 'folder2'
Type in 'gsutil' then '-m' for multicore, then 'cp' then '-r' for recursive, then the name of the folder 'folder2' then the name of the bucket 'gs://temporal-loop-94520'
If we refresh our Google Developer Console, we can see the new folder with all the files inside of it!